we've talked about ligo in many
different videos on this channel
including interviews with two of its
three Nobel prizewinning leaders Ray
Weiss and Barry beish and I hope to get
Kip Thorne on for a new video sometime
soon so that's great and you learn more
from that than you could imagine today
we're going to talk about ligo not as a
detector of gravitational waves as if
that weren't great enough we're going to
talk about it as a way of detecting Dark
Matter let's
go we're going to be discussing this
paper which describes Advanced ligo and
Lisa a future spaceborn version of ligo
as ways to detect dark matter by Evan
Hall and Nancy agarwall this is looking
for what's called a scalar field ultra
light Dark Matter candidate which have
become popular we're combining together
two different great Mysteries very
sensitive gravitational wave detectors
not used for gravitational wave
detection and ex exotic canidates for
dark matter the most mysterious form of
matter energy in our whole universe
makes up 80% of the matter in the
universe and yet we only know of one
possible candidate for dark matter and
that's the nutrino I've talked about
that in this video called Dark Matter
already detected but in that video I
explained that it's not possible for The
observed number of neutrinos and their
observed masses or the limits that we
have on their masses to account for the
amount of dark matter that there is in
the universe there either has to be
another form of dark matter or as we
discussed with morai mgram and with
Stacy mcgau there must be a modification
to the laws of gravity two different
completely bipolar opposites in terms of
explanations this experiment could get
down to the heart of what's called a
particulate candidate for dark matter so
a so-called scalar field described by
the mathematics shown here could account
for dark matter if there were sufficient
abundances of these dark matter scalar
fields to close the gap between the
ordinary matter like the kind that we're
comprised of bionic matter and the
missing amount known as dark matter
these types of scalar Fields change
What's called the fine structure
constant which is the governing
parameter that controls the size and the
force of interactions between
electricity magnetism and what are
called photons the strength of
electromagnetism in quantum mechanics is
governed by the fine structure constant
the name fine structure dates to early
spectroscopists from the late 1800s
finding in the spectrum of glowing hot
hydrogen gas one observed that there
were strange lines that needed to be
accounted for these were later
discovered to be part of What's called
the program of quantum electrodynamics
by Richard feeman and others who found
the solution for what the fine structure
constant was its value but we don't know
what it is why it is what it is in fact
it has the value at ordinary
circumstances of about 1 divid
137 which leads many physicists to set
the number 13 37 as their combination on
their luggage locks for the TSA now if
there were a light scalar field it would
change the size of the atoms which is
parameterized by the same fine structure
constant and it would do so in a
periodic fashion in a way that ligo
could detect given its Exquisite
sensitivity to Tiny variations in the
size and scale of its cavities of its
laser lock cavities that we'll describe
in just a moment so you can measure the
frequency of a laser as it oscillates
inside of a solid and it would be
exquisitely sensitive to the change of
the atomic radius which would then if
shown to be periodic varying
sinusoidally as shown in the first
equations that would be evidence for a
scalar field which could then have an
Associated Mass which could then
possibly account for the amount of dark
matter which we observe we don't observe
the Dark Matter itself but we observe
that there must be dark matter in the
universe due this the scientists are
using ligo but not using ligo to detect
gravitational waves it's using the
phenomenal construction of what are
called the test masses and the lasers
cycling within it this is from the ligo
team how the so-called silica cavities
we have two different cavities that
we're looking at we have the fuse silica
cavity which is called a reference
cavity and then there'll be an
interference pattern which will be
generated at a modulated rate that will
oscillate periodically if this dark
matter scalar field exists and that will
change the effects of the
interferometric pattern so called
correlation function and that's what
they're looking for so any strain which
is what Lio looks for it has this what's
called a strain sensitivity is what how
you uh account for its performance any
noise in the signal or any signal that
is caused by the dark matter will cause
an oscillation difference between the
signals in the reference cavity and the
signals inside the control
signal so the Dark Matter could induce a
strain which would be periodic unlike it
wouldn't be random like jittery noise of
thermal vibrations or agitation from
dial effects and things like that on
much longer time scales these would be
much shorter and ligo is well positioned
to measure it so thermal noise is random
it doesn't repeat periodically the way
that a putative Dark Matter signal could
I heard a ruckus could you describe the
Ruckus here's a graph of their
sensitivity which is really the ratio of
the signal to noise so the noise is
characterized here so now there's two
different ligo instruments two different
L-shaped interferometers one is in
Livingston Louisiana the other one's in
Hanford Washington the Hanford one is
far better for this particular type of
measurement has 10 times lower noise
across the wide spectral band and these
aren't like exotically extremely high or
extremely low frequencies these are
audio frequencies that you could hear
with your ears listen you smell
something and again what they're looking
for is to scan over these different
frequency terms and see if it's possible
for them to discern and pick out of this
Forest of lines that comprise the noise
background to see a modulated entire
time signal consistent with the Dark
Matter candidate so here's their
ultimate limit we won't go through the
math there won't be any homework for
this uh you can read the paper if you're
interested in more of the details but
this is uh describing in this paper the
limits that they could get to with more
and more measurements and then
eventually a much quieter location with
lower brownie in motion from thermal
noise and lower vibrational noise from
not being located on the earth is the
leas emission shown here a conceptual
design of it this could be launched in
the next decade or so and then this
could lead to a limit on the mass which
is characterized as all particle masses
are characterized by by their electron
volt energy divided by the speed of
light squared this is just relating the
rest mass energy eal mc^2 dividing by
c^2 and getting the equivalent Mass so
the researchers found they could use
ligo's laser frequency in the reference
cavity and the interferometer itself to
measure the coupling of an ultra light
scalar field Dark Matter candidate to
the standard model particles these would
be the particles like the electrons in
the crystal inside the the cavities that
make up the actual cavities themselves
those are just made of ordinary matter
they're not making it out of exotic dark
matter or unobtanium that's the only
reason they don't require any special
runs of the instrument they can get this
in real time as ligo is catching the
behavior of exploding black holes of
exploding supern perhaps coalescing
neutron stars and especially its main
most productive source of discovery
which are coalescing black holes it can
do this search for dark matter at no
cost in time sensitivity error budget it
can do that search at the exact same
time so it's very efficient use of this
exquisitely sensitive and pricey
instrument cost about a billion dollars
over its 20 or so year lifetime so stay
tuned we may ultimately get the best
possible data on these ultr Light Dark
Matter candidates not from this
groundbased instrument but from space
the Lisa instrument stay tuned for more
information about that and if you'd like
to learn more about ligo click this
video here and I'll see you in the next
episode
he